So, here at "Late Night," every
night I deliver a monologue
made up of jokes written
by a diverse team of writers.
As a result, a lot of jokes
come across my desk
that, due to my being
a straight white male,
would be difficult
for me to deliver.
But we don't think that should
stop you from enjoying them.
So we'd like to share them
with you now
in a segment called
"Jokes Seth Can't Tell."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, everybody,
these are two of our writers.
That's Amber.
And that's Jenny.
-I'm Black.
-And I'm gay.
-And we're both women.
-And I am not.
So, here's how this work.
I will read the setups
for these jokes,
and Amber and Jenny will read
the punch line.
So, here we go.
Kim Jong-Un has reportedly
banned citizens in North Korea
from wearing leather jackets.
-Lesbians are calling it
a human rights violation.
[ Laughter ]
-February is
Black History Month.
-Offer not valid in Virginia.
[ Laughter and groaning ]
It's not.
-A theater in Portland recently
hosted the opening
of the world's first
lesbian opera.
-A lesbian opera is like
a regular opera,
except it's not over
till the cat lady sings.
[ Laughter and groaning ]
-It's a cat crowd.
I should have told you guys.
Heavy cat crowd tonight.
-Cat crowd!
-I came out here earlier...
[ Laughing ]
...and I was like,
"David Letterman is here,"
and they're like, "Oh, there
gonna be cat stuff?!"
[ Laughter ]
A Miami museum has curated
an exhibit
about African American jockeys
called "Too Black, Too Fast."
-It's named after the reason
cops give for pulling me over.
[ Audience groans ]
-Amber!
-Just kidding!
Cops don't give me a reason
for pulling me over.
-Oh, okay.
[ Laughter ]
According to new research,
female dolphins enjoy
lesbian sex.
-While male dolphins enjoy
asking them how it works.
[ Laughter ]
-Now -- Now, Jenny...
-Mm-hmm?
-Is "how does sex work?"
the question lesbians get most?
-No, the question we get most
is, "Can you open this jar?"
-Mm.
Oh! That reminds me.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-Ah, there you go.
-Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Do you want a pickle?
-What do you think?
-Oh, right.
[ Laughter ]
This is where...
-Take this home.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
-We have so much pickle
on the desk.
-You got dressed up and you're
going to stink like pickle
for frickin' David Letterman,
you douche.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's Jenny's fault for
splashing the jar everywhere.
[ Laughter ]
Philadelphia has unveiled
a new Harriet Tubman statue
that will only be on display
temporarily.
-So catch her before she's gone,
said slave owners.
[ Audience groans ]
[ Laughing ] She's --
She's fine with that joke.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
An angry neighbor sent a lesbian
couple in Massachusetts a letter
complaining about
the couple's pride flag.
-And then the lesbians
sent one back
complaining about the neighbor's
poorly built deck.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, Jenny, are you handy?
-Yes, but never
on the first date.
[ Audience cheering ]
-An all-Black group is planning
to climb Mount Everest.
-Which is just
a fancy way of saying
they're going to try to vote
in Texas.
-Now, Amber, why don't more
Black people climb mountains?
-We're just trying to let
white people have something.
-Thank you.
-You climb the mountains.
-The new reboot of
"Sex and the City" features
several queer characters.
-Also featuring several
queer characters --
your food co-op.
-Two Black queer women recently
opened a new lesbian bar
in Chicago.
-[Together] And we're --
-Jenny, this is a Black joke.
-Amber, this is a lesbian joke.
-Black joke!
-Lesbian joke!
-Ohh!
Looks like it's time
for a quick draw!
Two Black queer women
recently opened
a new lesbian bar
in Chicago.
-And you know
they're serving Busch.
-"We're doing shots,"
said the police.
[ Laughter ]
Seth.
Seth, buddy, which one of those
jokes did you like better?
-When asked to choose
between a Black writer
and a lesbian writer,
I choose not to.
-Oh, smart.
-Mm.
Hey, Seth, why don't you
tell a joke?
-Oh, no, guys, I couldn't.
-Come on, just one.
-I don't feel like
it will end well.
-Oh, come on. Do it!
-Okay, okay.
The Chicago Bulls recently
celebrated Pride Night
with a halftime
drag performance.
"Boo!
Get back to the basketball!"
said lesbians.
-[ Gasps ]
How dare you?
-You told me it would be okay!
-You should be ashamed
of yourself.
-Black women and lesbians
are liars!
♪♪